hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game uh it took place a few
hours ago uh in defeated Tres Olympiad
it's around three it's Hare Krishna
versus Demetrius matravaslis board one
uh in the India a team versus Greece and
it's a game that features a beautiful
beautiful double Bishop sacrifice uh not
the one like you you would imagine for
like like maybe in Alaska power game
it's the famous one of course everyone
knows this and these gentlemen will not
fall for uh for such a trick but this is
one I'm pretty sure you guys haven't
seen before and it um the First bishop
sacrifice it's a pretty standard one but
the second one when that gets sacrificed
uh it's um you know just just to win a
single square and that makes all the
difference but not to spoil too much
um as it's a very short game we're gonna
get to it like pretty much instantly uh
let's uh let's check it out yeah so Hari
Krishna has the white pieces and he
opens with C4 he goes for the English
opening we have of E6 the Asian core
defense Knight to F3 D5 and now Pawn to
G3 preparing to think at the light
Square Bishop Knight to F6 Bishop to G2
and Bishop to E7 uh transposing to the
neocatal and we have Castles by both
players and now Pawn to D4 and we are
now uh completely uh shifted over to the
to the closed Catalan with Pawn to C6
and Knight to C3 Knight B to D7 and now
the botwinic variation Queen to D3 uh we
have B6 preparing to shift the bishop
over to A6 as the queen and the Rook
around this Diagon also could be very
good for black panther B3 and now A5 we
have Pawn to E4 striking in the center
uh and Bishop to A6 now we have Pawn to
E5 attacking the Knight Knight the E8
and now the position has been reached
before interestingly in 2014 between
Vladimir kramnik and baramiche and that
game ended in a draw but in that game uh
kramnik played Ponte H4 right away but
here harik Krishna shows that he has
improved upon kramnik's game and he
plays Pawn to A4 interestingly Ponte A4
is the engine's top recommendation and
pawn to H4 depending on the engine is
maybe the second or third recommendation
so uh definitely an improvement by Harry
here and of course it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game so
let's see uh how uh how Master vasilis
continues with knights the C7 uh he
wants to play B5 so Rook to B8 will come
then B5 and he wants to make this
diagonal come alive so here Rook to D1
uh getting the Rook away from this
diagonal and also putting it on the D
file uh H6 and now Pawn to H4 we've
rooked the B8 again preparing that B5
push and Bishop to F4 at developing the
bishop connecting the Rooks uh and now
it is black the plate what do you do
here well we've prepared B5 so Pawn to
B5 C captures on B4 5 we have C captures
on B5 and now you want to move the queen
so Queen to C2 and now the Rook no
longer uh has all that much to do on the
B file so Rook to C8 aligning The Rook
nicely with the queen here Rook D to C1
and now comes Bishop to B4 it seems like
maybe you could have some tricks here
because the rook and queen are here
let's say B4 attacks tonight the problem
is after the Knight moves uh there is no
Discovery you can use there's nothing
you can capture so it's uh you know it
looks nice but it doesn't really do all
that much so instead Bishop to B4 now
you have to be careful ah and now just
Queen back to D1 uh we ignite the B6 uh
and now Knight the H2 preparing to shift
the Knight over to G4 with B captures on
A4 Knight captures an A4 Knight captures
B captors and now Queen to E7 uh also
the developing the queen connecting the
Rooks Knight the G4 and now comes Knight
the A8 and this is a big problem for
black and we have reached our position
from the thumbnail the problem is uh you
have to move this Knight but not the A8
you have to move it over to E8 because
from E8 the Knight guards the F6 square
and now if White had some ideas of maybe
sacrificing the bishop let's say Bishop
captures and H6 you don't care G
captures and the df6 square is nicely
covered by the Knight so there will be
no Knight to F6 action however here at
Knight the eight was played and even
though it doesn't seem like you the
bishop can be sacrificed because it just
doesn't appear that there is enough
compensation there is a move that allows
it and that's really really a thing of
beauty so here Bishop captures an H6
yeah this is what Harry played and since
you already played Knight to eight it's
kind of your obligation to take the
bishop otherwise you just have to admit
that you missed this move completely so
G character 7 H6 and now Knight to F6
with check you can see now if the the
night was here like we discussed you
could just capture this Knight now you
can't the king is in check King to G7
hoping that maybe you can play something
like Rook to h8 get the king back to f8
maybe survive the attack but of course
uh Hari Krishna will not allow this
queen to G4 with check King the h8 now
comes Queen to F4 threatening Checkmate
uh black repeats King to G7 and then now
comes the move that um uh well as we did
say it's a double Bishop sacrifice
Bishop captures on D5 now it's a really
a weird move and it doesn't
immediately uh you know scream why you
should play this and the thing is you
want to win the F5 square if you win the
F5 Square it is game over uh point being
that after e captures on D5 you just
play Queen to G4 with check and once the
king moves and now you play Queen to F5
which would be impossible if the pawn
was an E6 guarding the F5 square and
there is no defense against Queen to H7
checkmate so black will have to give up
the queen but of course the position is
completely winning for white so after
Bishop captures on D5 uh Bishop to D3
was played uh trying to claim this
diagonal but now uh well all sorts of
moves are winning here uh Hari Krishna
plays the uh the nicest variation
basically Knights the H5 with check King
to H7 and now Bishop to E4 with check
and it was in this position unmove 30 uh
that Dimitrius Master vasilis resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so truly a spectacular game uh
for for pental Hari Krishna who who
plays this uh brilliant see like truly a
gem of a game and you know 30 moves on
board one in the in the Olympiad I mean
this is just incredible and what what a
double Bishop sacrifice okay the second
Bishop sacrifice was not accepted but um
it's lost regardless if you accept it or
not uh so really really enjoyable
um uh you know just Bishop captures on
D5 incredible trying to win that F5
Square here you resign because after the
bishop let's say Bishop capture Sun E4
you're gonna capture this with check and
once the king or you play for example at
5V captures on F6 Alpha song uh then you
win the queen and you win the game and
if king sorry if after Queen characters
I need for checking the h8 you just play
Rook captures on C8 and then of course
you play Knight to F6 and again black
cannot defend against this Checkmate you
either have to give up the queen which
is completely winning for white or you
go here and then we just Checkmate the
black king this way now this is
Checkmate this is Checkmate this is
Checkmate so whatever you want to do
yeah you know it's perfect fine
uh so yeah uh beautiful beautiful game
only 30 moves after Bishop to E4 and
master sales resigned to the game and
well I I enjoyed it immensely hope you
guys enjoyed it as well uh if you have
any of your own favorite games from
round three uh do share we will try to
cover as many as as as possible uh so
use a hashtag suggestion it is the
easiest way for me to check out your
comments uh so yeah another great
victory for uh A Team India uh we'll see
what happens in round four will they be
able to to push uh like this all the way
and uh now I think we're gonna be uh
starting to see some some big clashes
starting starting from tomorrow uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to mitkens uh happy 20th
birthday to mitkins and I would like to
thank Joshua Figueroa Lin tag Richard
Nickerson Allison Silva and David Kimura
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Olympiad until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day